elle sera finalement resté fermé une
semaine pour raisons économiques la
piscine mont boron de versailles a
rouvert ses portes ce lundi 12 septembre
la ville a réussi à trouver un accord
avec le délégataire de la piscine vers
marine comme l'a annoncé le maire de la
commune françois de mazières heureux de
vous annoncer que vers marine m'a
informé rouvrir la piscine mont boron ce
lundi la ville de versailles achètera le
gaz et l'électricité nécessaire via les
contrats qu'elle a conclu avec ses
fournisseurs d'énergie pour les revendre
au même montant à vert marine un accord
qui soulage financièrement le
délégataire du site qui a chuté
l'énergie pour chauffer la piscine selon
les prix du marché du moment dans ces
conditions la piscine peut donc rouvrir
et ils étaient nombreux devant la
structure ce lundi matin il y avait
notamment ce groupe d'étudiants et leur
professeur ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir moi j'ai apprécié fin ici dans
le sens où j'habite à versailles et bah
je passe beaucoup de temps et l'ait fait
qu'elle a été fermé ça va vraiment fait
quelque chose soccer c'est assez
embêtant puisqu'on pouvait plus entraîné
avec avec les gars du coup
là c'est cool on va pouvoir reprendre
et puis on a vu sa faim cerveau
aujourd'hui on a eu l'information au ce
matin donc c'est super sympa c'est cool
j'étais content un peu surpris je
pensais que ça allait durer plus
longtemps la fermeture et puis voilà les
choses se sont produites les accords
entre la ville et vers marine seront
valables au minimum jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 plusieurs piscines sont
encore fermés dans les yvelines comme
mantes la jolie ou encore conflans
sainte honorine